Quando pensate alla parola studio cosa
vi viene in mente
probabilmente libri compiti verifiche
esami ma quello che vi propongo oggi è
di andare oltre a questo cresce e di
riflettere sull'atto di studiare in sé
come una questione umana fondamentale
tutti noi sappiamo che lo studio è
importante per il nostro futuro ma
quanto spesso ci soffermiamo a
riflettere sull'atto di studiare in sé
in un'epoca in cui qualsiasi cosa a
portata di click lo studio richiede una
scelta deliberata di dedicare tempo ed
energie ad una determinata attività
lo studio richiede impegno pazienza e
sacrificio Come diceva il famoso
inventore tomase Edison il genio e l'1%
di ispirazione e il 99% di sudore
lo studio richiede lavoro duro e
costante ma è solo attraverso questa
perseveranza che possiamo raggiungere il
successo
Purtroppo viviamo in un'epoca in cui la
cultura dell'immediatezza ci spinge a
cercare gratificazioni istantanea e
risultati veloci
lo studio invece richiede pazienza un
impegno a lungo termine e richiede di
mettere da parte le distrazioni per
concentrarsi sul compito
occorre persuadere molta gente che anche
lo studio è un mestiere e molto faticoso
con un suo speciale tirocinio oltre che
intellettuale anche muscolare nervoso È
un processo di adattamento e un abito
acquisito con lo sfottò la noia e anche
la sofferenza
Queste sono le lapidarie parole di
Antonio Gramsci
che mi conosce sa che ho sempre messo il
primo posto Il mio sforzo per studiare
studio Innanzitutto perché mi piace
studio perché Lo reputo un dovere studio
per diventare una versione migliore di
me stessa per essere e restare libero
libera come le mie mucche al pascolo che
accudiscono nell'azienda della mia
famiglia e montagna che è tanta fatica
tanta stanchezza mi hanno regalato
quelle loro necessità in questi anni ed
ho capito Grazie a loro che sacrificio
non pesa affatto e non si prova per ciò
che si vuole e si ama veramente
la ricerca ha dimostrato che il
multitasking e l'uso di dispositivi
elettronici possono ridurre
significativamente la nostra capacità di
apprendere e ricordare le informazioni
il quoziente intellettivo è in costante
diminuzione da ormai troppi anni nel
mondo occidentale
ciò deve preoccuparci
lo studio non è solo una questione di
perseveranza e autocontrollo Ma richiede
anche un impegno per la curiosità e la
scoperta come diceva Infatti Albert
Einstein non ho Talenti speciali sono
solo appassionatamente curioso
noi come esseri umani abbiamo bisogno di
studiare e imparare continuamente per
sviluppare il nostro potenziale e per
adattarci all'evoluzione della società
Nelson Mandela affermava convinto che
l'educazione è l'arma più potente che
possiamo usare per cambiare il mondo non
è straordinario
il vero studio non termina con la fine
dell'educazione formale e scolastica Ma
continua per tutta la vita
c'è un Kennedy diceva che la leadership
e l'apprendimento sono indispensabili
l'uno all'altro
lo studio ci aiuta a crescere come
Individui e come professionisti a
rimanere aggiornati sulle ultime novità
a sviluppare il nostro potenziale
la nostra capacità di pensiero critico
uno dei principali vantaggi dello studio
ritengo sia quello di migliorare le
nostre capacità di prendere decisioni
informate
studiare ci aiuta a comprendere meglio
il mondo che ci circonda ed acquisire le
conoscenze necessarie per fare scelte
sagge e consapevoli
e noi giovani di scelta dobbiamo farne
tante in un'epoca confusa fragile e di
transizione come quella che stiamo
vivendo dove la tecnologia sta prendendo
sempre più il sopravvento sull'umanità
questo mi discorso infatti è stato in
gran parte scritto in una manciata di
secondi da un intelligenza artificiale
Sì avete capito benissimo non l'ho
scritto io bensì un computer
se studiare vi annoia vi stanca sopra
misura vi genera anche un po' d'anzietta
quella State tranquilli e continuate a
farlo Anzi fatelo con Maggiore intensità
con Maggiore forza sono i sintomi che lo
studio vista plasmando Sta facendo
effetto vi sta trasformando in persone
consapevoli
preservandovi come esseri umani pensanti
studiate studiamo la risposta ai nostri
dubbi su chi siamo su cosa vogliamo fare
sul perché siamo qui nessuno sicura
arriverà
[Applauso]